you know hey look at someone's eyes and
say oh my gosh I got right look at look
at that guy he looks happy he looks so
happy the one next to and isn't really
seem too happy he seems kind of annoyed
a little bit
this guy's angry what wait a minute this
guy I think he likes me look at her
right here she's flirting with me she
just crossed the line she's flirting
she just flirted with you know how we
can tell when we look at someone's eyes
the same when we look at someone's eyes
and we can see different emotions we can
also tell whether somebody is dreaming
or not today I'm going to share with you
five reasons why people stop dreaming so
this last week I'm at the Venetian with
45 people on my suite and we're going
back and forth with questions and have
this fifth year old man to my right sit
around 50s and a lady in her mid-40s is
asking me questions and we're going back
and forth and while I'm given an answer
she's smiling but she starts crying I
said why are you crying she says Pat I
don't believe my dreams can become a
reality
that led to a 45-minute conversation
which prompted me to want to make this
video number one Paulo Coelho the author
of The Alchemist once said that when we
turn when you and I turned 23 24 years
old
our brains something happens to it well
we become more logical we're no longer
oh my gosh this is possible I can take
over the world I don't know if I can
really take over seems kind of
impossible if you really think about it
there's no way in the world we can build
something like this so we go into this
whole different state of thinking right
now the possibility thinking is not out
there that makes me to a little bit more
about this go back 2011 seven years ago
I'm in my room in my office in Woodland
Hills Y by Warner Warner Center Marriott
I have made a friend I had known her for
four or five years we don't business
together very smart guy loved him loved
his wife good-looking family went to
Wharton Business School sharp as hell
brilliant guy he comes to me after
meeting at Cheesecake Factory because he
says I'd like to invest I want you to be
the CEO I want to be your CEO or
president we go build this company to
get us a great let's meet so we finally
meet in the office it's 12:30 we're
about to finalize the information to go
into contract and the number we agreed
at this time there's nothing taking
place good at this time with the company
we're trying to build that it's a lot of
work but we've been around for a year
and a half there's some track record so
we come up with this number around a
half a million dollars for 10% the
company you know what he ends up telling
me that not here's what it
you know what Patrick I said what's that
I feel like you're very good negotiator
and you're very good in sales I said
okay that's that's a good thing I'm that
just means that you're very smart to
team up with somebody like that that's a
very good salesperson negotiated because
you've told me before that's not your
strength your strength is more
operational technology yes I said so
what do you want to team up with a guy
that is opposite strengths - who's
nodding that in sales and I go I'm
trying to and some what you're saying
with this he says well I just don't know
if I'm gonna get the best deal here I
said let me get this straight you're
getting 10% for only a half a million
dollars and I'm doing this because I
want you part of our team I just think
you're selling me there's some stuff I
don't know about I said okay no problem
we went our separate ways do you realize
if we'd a came with that investment his
investments gonna be somewhere between
15 to 20 million dollars today and he
would have excelled what happened
Wharton Business School way too logical
everything was about what if this
happens what if that happens what I
could just almost watch him thinking he
went all logical he didn't see the
emotional side he didn't say the social
capital division what we have going on
and it was afraid because he's
second-guess themselves you know you
know what it's like let me explain a
little bit deeper for you here so it
makes sense to you when you're 16 you're
a girl you're in high school 10th grade
11th grade someone flirts with you it's
cute you like it look oh my gosh I think
he likes me it's nice you share with
your friends when you're 45 you're
single maybe divorce and you meet
another man he's divorced and you meet
him somewhere he comes and talks to you
the approach sometimes is different you
know what happens here's what happens
wait a minute I know what you're trying
to do you float him with me right yes I
know what you want you only care about
one thing you're just trying to get in
my pants I'm sorry
what do you mean all you want from me is
once all men all they want is one thing
skeptic logical when you're skeptical
aaja cool the guy says eventually I'm
hoping I get into your pants because
that's what people if I like you like me
we should probably go in the bedroom and
have some fun together right yeah no
you're not yes what's wrong if I'm
flirting with you I'm trying to woo you
and chase you
sometimes your dreams are flirting with
you but you're not letting your dreams
for it because all you're doing is
saying I know what you're trying to do
with me you're just trying to get into
my pants of course your dreams are
trying to get into your pants
your dreams is here they want to get
into here you're not letting your garden
down so you don't let anybody in you
know what happens when you do that you
live a life with no dreams becoming a
reality do you really want their life if
you don't want that life
you have to open this up a little bit
and you have to set aside some of the
logical thinking allow for opportunities
come up that get you closer and closer
and closer to dreams number two you know
so many times parents adults are so
concerned about the f-bomb oh my gosh
she said the S word he said the B word
profanity we are so concerned about
preventing people from cursing right
while we forget the real profanity is a
whole different language it ain't
cursing here I'm more concerned about
this then I'm about this and let me tell
what I'm talking about
I can't do this there's no way in the
world we could do it
that's not possible that's impossible me
well what can I do
I've no one in my family's ever made it
you think I could do it it bar you you
can't do what are you talking about
Mario who and your families ever made
before you'll be able to do it right
that's the real profanity not this part
this is what we have to worry about
that's the language let me simplify it
for you say four of us are in a round
table we're sitting there Smee Mario you
and a friend of yours somebody comes up
and says here's what I'm thinking about
doing what's that I'm thinking about
starting an online business to deliver
food and I cook it on my house and I
bring you two and you get to choose menu
and we recruit chefs all over the place
I'm thinking about starting an online
over for personal trainers and they come
to you meet at a gym you pick a location
at six o'clock personal trainer shows up
at 40 bucks 30 bucks and there's reviews
I'm thinking about doing something like
that now watch two different ways this
thing goes ready here's the one that's
too logical I'll break your crazy it's
already probably been done I bet
someone's already doing it don't even
waste your time doing it no way in the
world don't waste your time ba ba ba ba
ba and you go that direction okay
what happened to that conversation done
same temperature ready now watch this
other person here oh my gosh that is
pretty cool what if we actually did pull
it off now maybe someone's done at all
but let's take a look at what could you
do that would be different what if you
had a scoring system for the personal
trainers what if the person that loses
weight there's also a gauge to say that
this person did this endeavor what if we
linked Fitbit to the personal training
app that's like to Oprah that there's a
leaders bulletin there's a gamification
their room just got hot you know why
because the language is
bigger language this doesn't mean this
idea is gonna become a reality but it's
an environment that's going to give
birth to something gets warmer and
warmer and warmer and possibilities in
that room your biggest concern when it
comes down to a language isn't this is
to have a language that says what if
imagine what if we could do it imagine
if this becomes a reality that keeps
getting the energy going it engages
people while the other language does not
number three the next point is limiting
beliefs listen there are two different
ways that people have these limiting
beliefs that they don't believe they can
do it and here's two ways one way is you
have somebody else influences and
imposes their limiting beliefs on you
hey John this is who you are
you're a guy that was raised in a family
that has this they're divorced you
belong in this box stick to this go to
the military you're gonna have a good
life they're gonna give you a good
four-year degree at 39 years old you'll
retire with $2,800 income with benefits
you meet somebody good this is a good
life you go here stick you stay in this
box
yeah the kind of limiting beliefs is you
do to yourself let me give you an
example on the first set here of
limiting beliefs everybody sort of
dwayne johnson AKA rock right many many
years ago when you got in the scene of
wrestling you know he was a football
player he heard him sabi was playing for
the Miami Hurricanes and he when I
played some other semi-pro football and
then boom he's done there's careers over
with he's devastated he knows he can go
to wrestling why his father was arrested
so he goes into wrestling and they kind
of use him as a regular guy to do some
stuff and it was kind of like you know
not really a good guy a bad guy type of
thing and then they're just kind of
putting him as here go do this and go do
that and they thought the rock was just
another guy that was excited about being
arrested they thought I was it that's
Rob's dreams that's all he has you know
rock just go out there make you you
follow in your father's footsteps and
that's it for him one day the rock says
listen I got a set the tone here people
got to really realize who I'm all about
he goes in the ring gets his Vince let
me just talk tonight he grabs the mic
and he says the rock may be a lot of
things but there's one thing the rocks
not the rock doesn't suck
[Applause]
but such he said I had to say this to
the world because the world had to
realize what I'm all about because
that's how I view myself I am NOT going
to let the wrestling world put a certain
identity on me I know exactly what I
want to do do you know when he met with
his agents they asked him who do you
want to be he says I want to be like
Will Smith except bigger
he said that who says things like this I
want to be Will Smith except bigger this
guy didn't let anybody put a certain
limit and belief on him and it changed
and by the way he could have been a
wrestler and people would have said oh
he did good he followed his father's
footsteps became a wrestler
congratulations Rockets not want to be a
wrestler you know how much money he made
last year Forbes highest-paid actor ever
in a single year a hundred and
twenty-four million dollars last year
you don't think a lot of people put a
lot of limiting beliefs on him hey
football player you failed football
players get 12 million dollar year
contract this guy made in one year what
football players making 12 million a
year making 12 years that's the rock
that's why the rock is who he is so I'm
going back to you here by the way about
dreaming you have certain limiting
beliefs if you're now dreaming and seen
it become a reality there's something in
that you don't know what it is I made a
video a couple years ago I don't know
how long ago this was this maybe two
years ago and it's called how to
overcome your limiting beliefs if you
haven't watched it you have to watch
this video but when you watch this video
you need a paper and pen it's not gonna
work if you don't have something to
write on
to be able to address some of your
limiting beliefs so you can cross them
over and go and start dreaming again and
realize that great life that you want is
out there number four so look sometimes
I hear people tell me and say Pat the
reason why I don't dream anymore is
because I didn't grow up in an
environment that gave me an opportunity
to dream you know I didn't have my dad
wasn't successful I wish I had a father
like you Pat I wish I had an uncle like
you Pat because I would have an example
like do you realize how lame of an
excuse that is you realize LeBron's
father was never in the picture for him
to look up to somebody to go become who
he is today Reynaldo didn't have a
father figure to say oh my gosh this is
the person I'm gonna go play Michael
Jordan's bad that I'm playing
professional basketball
a lot of these stories you read about
they didn't have necessarily an example
that became that successful but these
people use some sort of inspiration to
go out and do it by the way when I was
coming up there was no YouTube there was
nothing for us to look at and be
inspired by today you can simply pick up
your phone and go watch a video
documentary of somebody and say oh my
gosh I'm inspired I want to go do this
as well you don't necessarily need a
mother and a father that have been super
successful for you to go out there and
say now I have an example to lead
there's plenty of inspiration everywhere
number five look this next one is
dedicated to anybody about 40 or 50
years old a matter of fact if you are
not 40 or 50 shared this clip with them
and tell them to go to the exact minute
it's on because they have to watch this
this is for you if you're above 40 or 50
your son or daughter shared it with you
you got to watch this look here's what
happens as we age when you're 17 years
old you haven't attended a lot of
funerals yet when you're 28 years old
you also have an attend a lot of
funerals yet do you know what happened
Mario what happened three hours ago from
a text I got that I showed you that you
said there's no way in the world that
just happened somebody else wrote it's a
very good friend of mine you just
finished writing a book I said
congratulations he says I'm in the
hospital why are you in the hospital for
you or somebody else it's for me I just
had a stroke what do you mean you just
had a stroke so you know what happens we
get older family dies some are younger
than us dies that's a very bad thing
when that happens because that's when we
start asking a question all these
tragedy starts happening around you
everything and you don't know it but
here's how people process it let me
process a couple of ways with you oh my
gosh
that person probably died from a lot of
stress and you know what I've been under
a lot of stress lately I mean honestly
what's really more important you know is
it more important for me to have my
health it versus me going and chasing
and making all this money who cares
about all this money I make anyways you
don't know you're doing this we know
what you're really trying to say
obviously health is more important than
all the money in the world but here's
what you're really saying you're saying
it is not possible to be healthy and
have money that's really what you're
saying and so all these things that you
get more defeated you get a divorce
you're 38 years old oh my gosh I'm 38
year old and I'm divorced I'm done who's
gonna want to be with somebody like me
you're 52 when you get a divorce you
lost your house you have nothing the
only thing left use twenty-two thousand
dollars on a dog
nothing you have nothing going on I mean
who's gonna want to be with somebody
like me I'm done I'm defeated so you
just get smaller and smaller and smaller
and smaller smaller you just deal with
life you just live with regular nothing
crazy
you just hole you just glad you got a
job and that's it you just glad you're
part of a you know fantasy football
league and that's your excitement all
these are the people that start telling
you about dreams and what if and you
know one day and all this other stuff
oh and knock it off when you live my
life it's a very hard life when you grow
up you'll know exactly how I feel
two suggestions I'll make to you if you
have kids and you're a parent and you're
watching this and you're in that state
you got to snap out of it here's why
your kids are watching your behavior
your kids are watching your behavior and
you don't know it indirectly you're
teaching your kids also how to be
defeated that's number one
- nowadays with today's doctors and
today's medicine and today's technology
if you're 4550 you've only lived half of
your life you you're gonna live another
55 50 to 55 years you want to spend
another 50 to 55 years there just being
down on yourself and nothing is possible
do you realize today's fifty
five-year-old this forty years ago is 35
year old can you say it again
today's fifty five-year-old this 30
years ago is thirty five-year-old you
ain't that old you're 35 today and
someone has to explain this to you so
what does this mean celebrate get
excited you got a lot of stuff ahead of
you man this is a beautiful life I mean
we got to take a look computer on my
phone this goes in my pocket can you
imagine a 486 computer putting in your
pocket back in the days no way in the
world that this is your Walkman remember
- orange Walkman is back in the days the
CD players you can't put that stuff
member we would work out the CD would
popper you can do it do you remember
those struggles you don't have those
struggles today you drive in your car
you don't even plug it in Wi-Fi picks up
the music wait a minute well how did all
this stuff come about progress progress
it's a complete different life but I
need you the 52 year old watching this
the 63 or watching is the 48 or watching
this spirit go back dream again life is
fine it's okay we're breathing man go
exercise go do something with your life
the
because this could potentially be the
beginning of the greatest years of your
life and potentially with this attitude
you could attract the most ridiculous
things in your life that can get you
closer to your dreams even though you're
62 years old even though you're 55 years
old because that's how dreams work
they're attracted to an attitude to a
persona to personality to mindset you
shift it they'll be turned on by you as
well if you go back and look at the last
100 videos and you see how many of the
videos I say what I'm about to tell you
right now it's probably gonna be zero I
very rarely comes out of my mouth and
says share this video with somebody else
I do believe this video has what it
takes to potentially completely change
someone's thinking which can lead to
change in their lives a lot of people
struggle with this topic
it's very emotional very sincere it's
very sensitive it's internal they don't
even talk about it because it's that
sensitive and so I think this is a video
you ought to share with your parents if
they're in their 40s 50s 60s share it
with them if you have somebody that's
younger defeated they've gone through a
bad loss also share this with them
because it's gonna get them thinking and
by the way if any of these stories
resonated with you I want to hear from
you send me a tweet at Patrick made
David I want to hear which of these
stories resonate with you again if you
haven't subscribed yet do so click on
that alert button to join a notification
squad and thanks for watching everybody
take care bye bye